Consider the lilies of the field,
how they grow.
They toil.
Not Neither do they spin,
and yet I say unto you that even Solomon
in all his glory was not arrayed like
one of these.
Wherefore,
if God so clothes the grass of the
field,
which today is and tomorrow is cast into
the oven,
shall he not much more clothe you,
oh ye of little faith.
Therefore take no thought saying,
what shall we eat or what shall we drink
or wherewithal shall we be closed.
Those are famous lines and that sort of
Christ the Hippie,
right?
It's like,
Hey,
let it all hang out.
That's an old phrase.
Do your thing and everything will come
to you and these lines have been
interpreted in that manner many times,
but that's seriously not the proper
interpretation because there's a kicker
with this injunction and the kicker is
this,
for your heavenly father,
know that you have need of all these
things,
but seek ye first the Kingdom of God and
his righteousness and all these things
shall be added unto you.
That's a lot different than the hippie
thing,
right?
Because there's a very,
very,
very interesting idea here.
It's,
it's certainly one of the most profound
ideas that I've ever encountered and the
idea is this,
is that if you configure your life so
that what you are genuinely doing is
aiming at the highest possible good,
then the things that you need to
to survive and to thrive on a day to day
basis will deliver themselves to you.
That's a hypothesis and it's not some
simple hypothesis,
right?
Because what it basically says is if you
dare to do the most difficult thing that
you can conceptualize,
your life will work out better than it
will.
If you do anything else.
Well,
how are you going to find out if that's
true?
Well,
it's a Kierkegaardian leap of faith.
There is no way you're going to find out
whether or not that's true unless you do
it.
So no,
no one can tell you either because just
because it works for someone else.
I mean,
that's interesting and all that,
but it's no proof that it'll work for
you.
You have to be all in in this game.
And so the idea is seek ye first the
Kingdom of God and his righteousness.
It's like that's actually a fairly
important caution when you're talking
about not having to pay attention to
what you're going to eat or what you're
going to where it's like what it's
essentially saying is that those
problems are trivial in comparison and
the probability is that if you manifest
yourself properly in the world,
that those things will come your way is
extraordinarily high.
And I believe,
I believe that that's exactly right.
I mean,
I,
I've,
I've watched people operate in the world
and I would say that there is no more
effective way of operating the world
than to conceptualize the highest good
that you can and then strive to attain
it.
There's no more practical pathway to the
kind of success that you could have if
you actually knew what success was.
And so that's what this,
that's what this sermon is attempting
to,
to posit.
It's like in,
in the story of Pinocchio.
You know what happens at the beginning
of the story of Pinocchio is that Japan
wishes on a star.
We talked about that a little bit and so
what you pedal does is align himself
with the metaphorical manifestation of
the highest good he can conceptualize
and say,
he says he makes sure he makes a
commitment.
Let's say he aims at the star and for
him the star is the possibility that he
can take his creation,
a puppet whose strings are being pulled
by unseen forces and have it transform
into something that's our economists and
real.
Yeah,
well that's a hell of an ambition.
You know when we're wise enough to put
that into children's movie,
but too foolish to understand what it
means.
It's such an interesting juxtaposition
that that we can both know that and not
know it.
At the same time,
you can go to the movie,
you can watch it and it makes sense,
but that doesn't mean that you can go
home and think,
well,
I know what that meant.
While people are complicated,
right?
We exist at different levels and all the
levels don't communicate with one
another,
but.
But the movie is a hypothesis and the
hypothesis is there's no better pathway
to self realization and the enablement
of being than to pause it,
the highest good that you can conceive
of and commit yourself to it.
And then you might also ask yourself,
and this is definitely worth asking,
is do you really have anything better to
do?
And if you don't,
well why would you do anything else?
Therefore take no thought for the
morrow,
for the morrow shall take thought for
the things of itself sufficient unto the
day is the evil thereof.
I spent a long time trying to figure out
what that meant to because it's another
one of those lines that
can easily be read as pro grasshopper,
an anti amped.
You know you remember the old fable of
the grasshopper in the end,
maybe not,
I'm not going to tell it,
but works and the grasshopper fiddles
and the ad has a pretty good time in the
winter and the grasshopper dies.
And so this is like a pro grasshopper
line,
but it's not because it says something
else.
It says that if you orient yourself
properly
and then pay attention to what you do
every day that works,
and I actually think that that's in
accordance with what with what we have
come to understand about human
perception because what happens is that
the world shifts itself around your aim
because you're.
You're a creature that has an aim.
You have to have an ame in order to do
something.
You're in aiming creature.
You look at a point and you move towards
it.
It's built right into you and so you
have a name.
Well,
let's say your aim is the highest
possible ame.
Well then so that sets up the world
around you.
It,
it organizes all of your perceptions and
organizes what you see and you don't
see.
It organizes your emotions and your
motivations.
So you organize yourself around that aim
and then what happens is the day
manifests itself as a set of challenges
and problems and if you solve them
properly,
then you stay on the pathway towards
that eighth and you can concentrate on
the,
on the,
on the day,
and so that way you get to have your
cake.
And eat it too because you can,
you can point into the distance,
the far distance and you can live in the
day
and it seems to me that that's.
That makes every moment of the day
supercharged with meaning that that's
because if everything that you're doing
everyday is related to the highest
possible aim that you can conceptualize,
well,
that's the very definition of the
meaning that would sustain you in your
life well,
and then the issue is well back to noah.
Well all hell is about to break loose
and chaos is coming.
It's like when that's happening in your
life,
you might want to be doing something
that you regard as truly worthwhile
because that's what will keep you afloat
when,
when everything is flooded and you don't
want to wait until the flood comes to
start doing that.
Because if you're arcs half built and
you don't know how to captain it,
the probability is very high that
that you'll drown.